hey leute bevor das video losgeht wollte
ich euch nummer bescheid geben dass es
ein ernsteres video ist falls ihr also
heute keinen bock auf irgend ein ernstes
video und bild über die aktuelle lage
von youtube habt dann schaltet am besten
morgen wieder einmal was lustiges heute
bisschen ernster nicht dass ich
irgendeine auf den super lustiges video
freude dann kommen die premiere ist soll
rede wollt ihr euch nochmal gesagt haben
alles klar also alle die bock auf happy
content haben sonst vielleicht nicht
anschauen
für den rest interessiert bleibt dran
und dann alle bis morgen services kids
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video mit dem mir wie man mir das reh
mit dem markt heute möchte ich mal ein
bisschen ernster zu sprechen immer ein
thema ansprechen was mich in letzter
zeit viel beschäftige habt euch bestimmt
auch und zwar irgendwie läuft auf
youtube ja nicht so wie es laufen sollte
oder max hat dazu auch schon wieder
gemacht heißt es noch nicht gesehen habe
ich das und mal verlinkt und ich habe
heute eine liste mit themen gemacht die
ich ansprechen möchte weil ich finde
irgendwie in letzter zeit ist youtube so
feindlich geworden als ort so viele
querte machen nur noch scheiße ich mach
teilweise auch oft einfach scheiße gebe
ich auch offen zu möchte gern dass wir
da wieder ein bisschen besser zusammen
kommen also die youtuber und die
zuschauer im hintergrund sieht dem
gameplay of the world habe ich ein paar
escapes gespielt hier für mich gebaut
habt und wir legen jetzt mal los erstes
thema rote kreise
meine meinung zu holen kreisen ist ich
finde das rote kreise die vom ames
wirklich besser aussehen lassen
ich finde auch rote kreise so lange
nicht schlimm wie sie sinnvoll sind
ich habe zum beispiel letztens ein
chaotisches zusammen gemacht von dieser
flasche waren so viele dinge auf diesem
bild habe ich hatt einen kreis um die
kiste gemacht aber hinter dem roten
kreis war wirklich was es gibt ja so
viele youtuber die einfach rote kreise
einfach random draufpacken ohne dass da
irgendwas ist mich zu fragen warum es an
wo der kreis ja was sagst du dazu max
ich weiß nicht so genau diese rot kreis
geschichte erhitzt mein gemüt nicht so
krass irgendwie zuschauer regen sich
darüber auf dass
ist halt teil des cliq bate gesamtpaket
jedes video mit einem roten kreis zu
machen irgendwie und irgendwo sollte man
das ganze nicht ober yusen weil es gibt
halt auch zahllose andere möglichkeiten
um auf sachen aufmerksam zu machen als
mit so einem fetten roten kreis also du
kannst einfach dem ding irgendwie
krassen schlagschatten eine kontur
irgendwie sowas verpassen
also ich finde so kann man mal machen
aber die ganze zeit ist es halt stressig
weil das irgendwie wir halt krass
dominant dass oft am netz
das stimmt manchmal für eine rote kreis
wirklich dass du das dann besser
aussieht so aber alle leute rasten so
aus wenn den roten kreis sind so nach
dem motto ok daten roten kreis der hat
drei kinder umgebracht vier frauen
vergewaltigt und ein kilo koks im keller
wo der rote kreis macht noch nicht den
schlechten youtube also ich finde dass
sich die ganze diskussion zu sehr auf
diese kreise konzentriere ich meinen
dass die kreise sind eigentlich egal
ich persönlich denke mehrheit dass es
keinen sinn macht wie sehr diese kreise
verurteilt werden weil die kreise an
sehe ich da nichts schlimmes ich finde
wirklich die führen oft dazu dass es
dann einfach besser aussieht und so
lange was hinter dem kreis ist finde ich
auch nicht ganz so schlimm wie wenn man
die einfach so passiert ohne einfach
ohne grund na ja aber ihr könnt und und
sollte auch unbedingt leute auch mal
dazu in die kommentare schreiben
das ist ganz ganz wichtig weil wie
gesagt dass wir solch eine diskussion
anstoßen und ich verstehe deine
argumentation dass das also das ist ein
geringeres übel ich finde auch das hat
ein bisschen das wird vollkommen
überschätzt
die leute konzentrieren sich nur auf
diese roten kreise und kümmern sich um
gar nichts anderes mehr
das soweit dazu ok dann mag ich jetzt
noch weiter gehen zu dem thema klick
bett und vivi konnten youtuber dazu zu
klicken
also erstmal muss man eigentlich mal
definieren was es klick ich würde sagen
klick weit ist man verspricht mit titel
und fall etwas was das video nicht
einhalten kann
albert heiss köder ist eigentlich für
kühler man ködert quasi den zuschauer
auf das video zu klicken aber er bekommt
dann nicht das was er sich erwartet hat
durch den titel
ja ich könnte sagen man probiert halt
durch über alles was möglich ist
möglichst viel aufmerksamkeit zu kriegen
unabhängig vom inhalt
wenn der titel nicht mehr verspricht als
das video hält ist es dann immer noch
klick kate ja klar wenn ja wenn du ein
krasses mail über kritik schreibt ja
firma for use in orange ja und diese
branche wenn ihr video geklickt werden
hier bis bekommen dann entsagte dieser
branche so klingt ist so den letzten
tropfen aus dieser orange
rauszuquetschen damit man ja auch jeden
jedes letzte tröpfchen davon noch
bekommt also quasi jeden letzten video
bekommt und das stört die leute halt
oftmals habe ich manchmal erzählen wie
youtube dazu kommen und zwar irgendwann
fängt an irgendwelche krassen titel zu
verwenden
nach dem motto aufgabe hd gebannt und
dann ist einfach nicht gebannt worden
erzählt er eine geschichte keine ahnung
und dann denkt man sich so okay das ist
ein spaß
das passiert dann total oft man regt
sich über diese person auf und sieht
halt trotzdem dann halt genauso immer
weiter wächst oder zwei displays
passiert aber einfach nichts darauf gibt
du siehst wie die personen wächst werden
deinen kanal halt nicht stagniert aber
halt weniger gras wächst weil du nicht
bereit bist deine werte so krass auf zu
verkaufen
für views und dann denkt man sich so
menschen mache ich was falsch wenn ich
nicht so war so was nicht mache und
weniger erfolg habe mache ich da was
falsch so und dann irgendwann macht man
sich halt nicht drüber lustig sondern
denkt nach ob man das vielleicht einfach
machen musst um noch relevant zu bleiben
und dann führt das bei manchen halt dazu
dass man das dann einfach nach amt so
und so verbreitet sich diese krankheit
so nach dem motto einer macht irgendwie
scheiße die eigentlich nicht okay ist
und hat damit erfolg
andere creator sehens und es wurde die
weil sie denkt okay sagt er jetzt erfolg
mit so einer scheiße das ist ungerecht
und das sollte nicht machen und
irgendwann verbreiten sich das und ich
glaube die lösung dafür dass die ganz
einfache lösung dafür ist was man das
von anfang an nicht tolerieren darf
also man darf das nicht zulassen das ist
unsere verantwortung sowohl die von den
zuschauern als auch von den youtube dass
man wenn man sowas sieht dass irgendein
youtuber irgendwie scheiße macht
irgendwas falsch gemacht was moralisch
nicht in ordnung ist und damit erfolg
hat dann darf man das nicht nicht
zulassen nicht erlauben dagegen muss man
sich wehren weil sonst wird das
normalität sonst verbreitet sich das so
funktioniert das hat auf youtube
wenn irgendeiner mit irgendwas erfolg
hat dann verbreitet sich das relativ
schnell in andere machen das nach gut
aber diese ganz abgebrühten ignoranten
hunde machen das einfach so dass sie
dann trotzdem einfach nicht reagieren
wehrlose kritisierst machen weiter und
ich glaube bei so was kannst du kannst
du nicht viel machen außer die person
macht halten beim ist irgendwie macht
irgendeine ausrutscher und verwendet in
ihrem streben nach maximalem klicks
irgendwelche bilder an denen sie keine
rechte hatten dann wird der kanal
geschlossen
das wäre irgendwie doch der größte segen
bei manchen kann also in youtube
deutschland aber wenn die leute das
selbst nicht begreifen wollen dann
kannst du nichts machen
doch die leute müssen einfach auf heute
müssen einfach ihren tieren ihren kopf
benutzen
also wenn ihr als zuschauer irgendwie
den eindruck bekommt das in dem video
was seht was nicht geht zum beispiel
jemand macht sich über schule lustig
schulen dreck oder jemand verspricht im
fairplay was was im video überhaupt
nicht erscheint dann müsst ihr und
jürgen zuschauer müssen dann genau zu
diesem youtuber gehen und sagen so geht
das nicht
um es zusammenzufassen man darf juli auf
youtube scheiße einfach nicht tolerieren
man darf nicht zulassen dass scheiße
existiert und wenn irgendwo scheiße
existiert muss man entschieden dagegen
vorgehen und dann dafür sorgen dass die
person hat nicht 20 prozent des lacks
hat sondern 90 prozent hat irgendwann
versteht dass es so nicht geht ich finde
dass da ist die community noch nicht
kritisch genug objekt ist das macht das
also den unterschied aus dass ich das
nicht so ich hab das der grenzgänger
bist du was diese dinge angeht dass die
leute dich erhalten mal in die schranken
die schranken weisen wollen ich ja ich
bin auch irgendwie so ich bin irgendwie
ein bisschen dazwischen also ich bin
nicht so ganz so aus cool
let's player wie so max oder wenig zum
beispiel und ich bin nicht
folglich also leute meine aufforderung
ist glaube ich wenn wir wir wollen dass
youtube sich wieder von diesem komischen
zustand daems jetzt ist zu einem
angenehmen zustand wer hinweg entwickelt
dann muss man einfach aufhören scheiße
auf youtube zu tolerieren
das ist meine meine idee gut ist glaube
ich hab schwierig ich meine wir klicken
nicht manchmal auf diese du glaubst
nicht was mit dieser frau passiert ist
titel auf facebook die jetzt auch
manchen youtuber zu anwenden versucht
und auf eben diese ganzen sachen die
einfach dafür ausgelegt sind deine
aufmerksamkeit an sich zu ziehen wer
klickt dann nicht manchmal drauf aber
wenn man das schafft die ganze community
oder ein großteil dafür zu
sensibilisieren so zu handeln
dann wäre es auf jeden fall die heilung
sage ich mal
aber man kann halt auch nicht glauben
dass alle schlau genug sind oder weil er
nicht einfach alt genug nicht alle
interessiert dass nicht alle wärme zu
kapieren
er habe leute wenn es ihr kapiert dann
ist meine aufforderung an euch und das
ist das letzte wort in diesem video
wenn irgendjemand eine scheiße auf
youtube macht ihn nicht in ordnung ist
auch wenn ich das bin
dann macht die person darauf aufmerksam
und sagt ihr dass das so einfach nicht
geht wenn youtuber und community nicht
zusammen stehen und sich gegen
schlechten beschissenen klick paid
content wären dann geht den bach runter
und das kommt von einer person die den
selbst manchmal teilweise macht meine
aufforderung wenn irgendein youtuber
scheiße macht und sagt ihm dass wenn ich
scheiße macht sagt mir das und ich
glaube so können wir uns verbessern und
youtube great game machen hashtag
marketing leute wenn ihr das video bis
ende gescheitert dann schreibt in die
kommentare hashtag make you tube
greatecs das war unsere meinung dazu
ich habe das gefühl dass ich noch nicht
alles gesagt habe aber falls irgendwas
unklar ist aber so alles in den
kommentaren kommentare durch
unbeantwortet die
und ja sie können schaffen wir können
schaffen schaffen
ja okay alles klar in diesem sinne leute
leute rock ist es ein neues pokémon
wechsel müssen konversationen mit der
community toxo leute hat jetzt ein toto
gedacht okay leute in diesem sinne ein
hashtag make you tube kredite und macht